Jaime Lannister: As the saying goes, "Every
time a Targaryen is born, the gods flip a
coin."
They must have dropped the one for King Aerys,
for at first, he seemed to have dodged the
family madness.
But as he grew older, he began to see conspirators
everywhere, and where there were none, he
worked to create them.
As one of his Kingsguard, I saw firsthand
that a king who couldn't rule his own mind
couldn't rule Seven Kingdoms.
We endured his reign because we hoped his
son Rhaegar would ride the rail when he ascended
to the throne.
But then Rhaegar proved as mad as his father
and snatched Lyanna Stark, daughter of the
Warden of the North and betrothed to Robert
Baratheon, Lord of the Stormlands.
When Lyanna's father and eldest brother demanded
justice, the Mad King obliged, laughing as
he dispensed it.
Varys: Unsatisfied with only two murders,
the Mad King then ordered Jon Arryn, Lord
of the Vale, to execute his two wards, Robert
Baratheon and Eddard Stark.
Instead, Jon Arryn raised the Vale in revolt.
Ned Stark slipped past royalist sentries and
raised the North, and Robert won three battles
in a single day to unite the Stormlands behind
them, only to be defeated by a royalist army
and forced to flee, leaving his home of Storm's
End besieged.
Sansa Stark: The Hand of the King finally
cornered Robert in the town of the Stoney
Sept and sent his soldiers door-to-door, searching
for the rebel leader.
But the villagers hated the Mad King and loved
Robert, and kept him one step ahead of the
soldiers until only one refuge remained.
As the soldiers closed in, all the town bells
rang out.
Hearing of Robert's plight, our father and
Jon Arryn had rushed to the Riverlands and
enlisted our grandfather, Hoster Tully, to
help them.
Together, they routed the Hand's army and
rescued Robert.
To celebrate and cement the Tully alliance,
our father wed our mother, Catelyn, and Jon
Arryn took our aunt, Lysa.
Only a fortnight later, both men rushed back
into the field, for the dragon had finally
woken.
Viserys: While my father's servants were losing
my father's kingdoms, my brother Rhaegar had
been cooped up with his...Mistress?
Whatever else, I'd call her a distraction.
But now Rhaegar came to his senses and returned
to King's Landing.
He persuaded our father to summon his estranged
friend, Lord Tywin Lannister, the richest
and most powerful lord in the realm.
Rhaegar himself would lead the royal army
against the usurper, Robert.
On the banks of the Trident, my brother fought
the man whose wife he had stolen, and who
fought to steal his birthright in return.
In the end, Robert wanted it more.
His hammer shattered my brother's armor, and
its rubies fell into the river like raindrops,
vanishing in the current.
Varys: With Rhaegar's defeat, nothing stood
between Robert and King's Landing.
Imagine the King's surprise a fortnight later
when he saw not stags, but lions outside his
gates.
His former Hand, Tywin Lannister, had come
to the capital with a force even Robert couldn't
match, claiming to be loyal to the king.
Trusting what he wanted to believe, Aerys
ordered the gates opened, and the Lannister
forces dutifully began to pillage, and murder
the king's actual loyal subjects.
When Eddard Stark finally arrived at the capital
with Robert's army, he found Lannister banners
hanging over the sacked city, Targaryen corpses
littering its streets and Ser Jaime Lannister
sitting on the Iron Throne.
Below him, the Mad King Aerys, whom Ser Jaime
had sworn to guard, lay in a pool of his own
blood from a sword thrust through his back.
Lord Eddard might've thanked Ser Jaime for
doing the realm a favor, but honorable as
he was, Lord Eddard condemned Ser Jaime as
a "Kingslayer," a name he would never escape.
Jaime: Unlike Lord Eddard, Robert appreciated
my contribution to his glorious victory.
He pardoned me for my crime and even kept
me on his Kingsguard beside Ser Barristan
Selmy, who'd been wounded at the Trident fighting
for Rhaegar.
True, both of us had failed to protect out
Targaryen charges, but perhaps that's what
Robert liked most about us.
When my father presented Robert with the bodies
of Rhaegar's wife and two children, Ned Stark
hiked up his skirt and demanded Robert send
their killer to Dorne and me to the Wall.
But I saw what Ned couldn't.
Robert was ashamed of the bodies and more
ashamed of his relief.
He knew that Rhaegar's heirs had to die, or
his throne would never be safe.
But glorious heroes didn't kill children.
They simply didn't punish their murderers.
Varys: For three hundred years, the Targaryen
dynasty ruled Westeros.
Wars were still fought, homes still burned
and men still died, but compared to the chaos
of what came before, the realm was stable.
Petyr Baelish: And boring.
The Targaryens lied, thieved and killed as
much as other lords.
They just had dragons to answer all complaints.
Until they didn't.
When the last dragon died, it was only a matter
of time before the Targaryens followed.
Varys: By "only," you mean another century?
Baelish: Which they wasted trying to replace
their lost advantage: incinerating their own
palaces to hatch dragon eggs, drinking wildfire
to become dragons, and, let's not forget the
Mad King's favorite, burning men alive so
he could pretend to be a dragon.
Varys: We urged Aerys to pardon Brandon Stark.
The boy had threatened Prince Rhaegar, but
Rhaegar had stolen the boy's sister, and the
boy was the eldest son of our Warden of the
North.
Baelish: Who is the greater fool: a mad king
or the man who reasons with him?
Aerys saw knives in every shadow.
When you told him to treat the Starks with
caution, you made him afraid and what he feared
he killed.
Varys: I wouldn't have thought you of all
people would bother with recriminations for
Brandon's death, Lord Baelish.
Not after your, shall we call it, "duel" with
him?
Baelish: Brandon was as arrogant as he was
stupid; like his father, Lord Stark, who answered
Aerys' summon to the capital.
They earned their fates.
But the younger son, Ned, what was his crime?
That Aerys ordered his death as well?
Varys: Unlike men, families do not die when
you lop off their head.
Baelish: At the very least, you should have
pointed out that loyal and dutiful Ned was
living with Jon Arryn, a proud and over-righteous
lord with an impregnable castle and no sons
of his own.
Perhaps you could have spared Aerys the "embarrassment"
of revolt.
Varys: If only we'd had the foresight to consult
you, Lord Baelish, but I suppose first we'd
have had to know who you were.
Baelish: Nobody knew Robert Baratheon either,
yet he claimed the right to sit on the Iron
Throne.
Varys: He had Targaryen blood through his
mother.
Baelish: A pretty dress for an ugly truth:
it was war; and he could swing a hammer harder
than the other options.
When did you know you'd lost, Lord Varys?
Varys: When Robert Baratheon killed Prince
Rhaegar on the Trident.
Baelish: Wrong.
You lost the war when you let Ned Stark slip
back into The North.
Neither the Bloody Gate of the Vale or Moat
Cailin in the North have ever fallen.
They could have held out for years even if
you'd killed Robert, but you let him slip
through your fingers as well.
Varys: I told the court that Robert was hiding
in the Stoney Sept, but the Hand of the King
wasted too much time searching the city.
Something about the glory of single combat.
Then Ned Stark's army arrived to save the
day.
Baelish: Too bad Lord Tywin wasn't Hand any
longer.
He would have simply razed the town and been
done with it.
Varys: Perhaps.
And perhaps the rebels would have found even
more of the countryside flocking to their
banners.
Baelish: I'd almost forgotten.
You weren't always so loyal to the Lannisters
during the war, were you?
Varys: I did my duty to the realm.
When Lord Tywin showed up at King's Landing
professing loyalty, I warned Aerys not to
open the gates.
Prince Rhaegar was dead, our army scattered.
"The lion does not stir unless he smells meat."
Baelish: I admire your powers of persuasion,
Lord Varys.
Few could traffic on so many secrets to so
little avail.
Varys: Grand Maester Pycelle told Aerys what
he wanted to hear, that his old friend Tywin
was there to save him.
Baelish: Then Aerys's "old friend" sacked
the city, and his son stabbed Aerys in the
back.
Varys: A regrettable though necessary action.
Baelish: As were the pardons the new King
Robert bestowed upon the royalists: Mace Tyrell,
Barristan Selmy, you.
Varys: King Robert wisely chose order over
vengeance.
Baelish: Jon Arryn wisely chose for Robert.
But Jon Arryn died, then Robert, then Ned.
So ended their glorious revolution.
Margaery Tyrell: Under the Targaryen dynasty,
Westeros prospered.
Gone were the petty wars of Seven Kingdoms
and the endless thirst for minor glories that
drove them.
The Westerlands enriched the realm, the North
guarded it, and the Reach and Riverlands fed
it.
This harmony is what Robert Baratheon shattered
with his rebellion against Aerys Targaryen.
When the call to arms came, though, we did
not want to answer.
The Reach is a gentle land, and, honestly,
the Mad King was not much loved.
But we owed peace and status to his family.
My father, Mace Tyrell, called his banners
and marched north to battle the rogue Storm
Lord, Robert, who had already defeated three
forces in a single day.
And, at Ashford, my father won.
Some chasten my father for not pursuing Robert
after the battle.
We had cut him off from the Stormlands, the
seat of his power, and he had fled north,
within easy grasp of Lord Tywin Lannister,
the Hand of Aerys for twenty years.
My father moved instead to lay siege of Robert's
ancestral stronghold of Storm's End.
The rose would strangle the stag as the lion
pounced.
So we waited.
But the lion slumbered, and Robert slipped
past the King's forces to join Ned Stark.
We could have lifted the siege and deployed
our armies north to aid the Crown.
We could have stormed the walls of the castle
and made Robert homeless.
But we had ample supplies, control of land
and sea, and, most of all, patience.
Our siege would succeed, eventually, at little
cost of life to us.
If Robert prolonged the war with minor victories,
our capture of Storm's End would hasten his
downfall.
And if Robert won the war, well, it would
not do for him to find us within his walls
with the bodies of his brother Stannis and
his sworn men.
When the lion finally showed his colors and
"purged" King's Landing, we knew our cause
was lost.
My father chose the peaceful route and bent
the knee to Robert, who heartily pardoned
us.
Strange, considering how we had beaten him
and starved his brother to the brink of death.
Catelyn Stark: When I came of age, Brandon
Stark of Winterfell sought and won my hand.
To my father, Brandon was heir to the North
and a suitable match for a daughter of House
Tully.
To me, Brandon was wild and terrifying, never
far from laughter or trouble.
I loved him with all the fire of a first passion;
much, I came to realize, as Petyr loved me.
When Petyr heard of my engagement, he challenged
Brandon to a duel.
Petyr survived only because I begged Brandon
not to kill him.
I still thought of Petyr as family.
Now, I wish I had let him die.
Only days before my wedding, when I thought
I would be happy forever, Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
abducted Brandon's sister, Lyanna.
Hotblooded as always, Brandon immediately
rode for King's Landing to demand justice,
which the Mad King Aerys Targaryen gave him,
in his own twisted fashion.
The day the raven arrived with news of my
Brandon's death, I locked myself in my room
and refused to eat for days, until my father
reminded me of my duty.
I was to marry Eddard, Brandon's younger brother,
a man whom I had never met, of whom none spoke
ill or spoke anything at all.
Our union would cement an alliance of the
North, Vale, Stormlands, and Riverlands in
rebellion against the Mad King.
I was Tully.
I did my duty.
We were married quickly and were spared only
one night before he had to return to the field.
I spent the war by the window, waiting for
a raven to hear if my child would grow fatherless,
or at all.
We knew the price of defeat.
I scoured the kitchens and washing rooms for
any and all gossip.
Robert had won and crushed the Mad King!
Robert had lost, but Jaime Lannister was now
King.
Robert had almost won, but the Mad King had
become a dragon and burned King's Landing
to ash.
At night, I told myself the war would end
soon and bring peace: either a victory or
the grave.
I was wrong.
Robert won, and my husband avenged his brother
and my love.
But when he came home to me, he could not
meet my eyes.
I saw the reason by his side.
Many men have bastards, I know, and under
the strain of war, any man, no matter how
honorable, may forsake his vows for a night
of warmth that he may never know again.
But Ned Stark was not built like other men.
His northern honor would not let him sequester
his shame in some distant holdfast.
Barristan Selmy: All I ever wanted was to
live a life of honor, defending a king worthy
of service.
During the War of the Ninepenny Kings, I sought
out Maelys the Monstrous, last of the Blackfyre
pretenders, who had started this whole war.
Maelys believed that his Targaryen blood gave
him a claim to the Iron Throne.
I made sure that his blood claimed nothing
more than the dirt around his corpse.
To show his gratitude, the King elevated me
to his Kingsguard.
It was the proudest moment of my life.
But that king died, and I wasn't with him.
Not that I could have saved him if I had been.
But still, I vowed to do better with his son,
young Prince Aerys.
For twenty years, his reign was peaceful and
prosperous.
Aerys was well-loved by his subjects and respected
by his lords.
But as years went on, Aerys' temper soured.
He became obsessed with dragons and fire,
and the swords of the Kingsguard couldn't
defend him from the enemies he saw lurking
in every shadow.
My king went mad.
But there was hope; his son and heir.
Prince Rhaegar was everything a kingdom could
hope for in a ruler; he was strong but gentle,
wise and cautious, and a good friend.
No matter the wounds Aerys dug into the realm,
we had faith that his son would sew it back
together again when he ascended the throne.
Then came Lord Whent's tourney at Harrenhal,
the largest ever in Westeros.
I unhorsed every man against me until only
Prince Rhaegar remained.
We each set our feet in our saddles and lowered
our lances and charged, and I fell.
Muddy and bruised, I then watched Rhaegar
present Lyanna Stark with the victor's crown
of roses, though she was betrothed to Robert
Baratheon and Rhaegar himself was married
to Elia Martell.
We all know what happened after.
If I had I been a bit quicker with my lance,
had I chosen a faster horse, perhaps I could
have spared the kingdom from the destruction
that came after.
Or if I had thought to warn Brandon Stark
against his rashness.
He came to King's Landing himself demanding
Rhaegar return his sister.
Poor fool.
If he had only known the depth of Aerys' madness,
he wouldn't have dared provoke him.
Aerys ordered Brandon imprisoned, while I
could do nothing but obey.
When Brandon's father, Lord Rickard Stark,
came to King's Landing to beg for his son,
Aerys burned him alive, while I could do nothing
but watch.
I had sworn a vow to a mad king and was honor-bound
to obey him, even at the cost of my soul.
Ravens soon arrived with dark news for the
king; The Vale was in open revolt.
Demanding Lyanna Stark's return, Robert Baratheon
was smashing any army that dared face him.
Eddard Stark, Brandon's younger brother, was
marching the whole of the North down the Neck
and had taken Catelyn Tully, Brandon's betrothed,
for his own, thus winning the support of The
Riverlands.
The king sent ravens to Casterly Rock to beg
his former Hand, Tywin Lannister, for help,
and no ravens returned.
A plan was devised; Prince Rhaegar would personally
lead the royal forces, now reinforced with
ten thousand Dornishmen, north to face Robert,
while the Kingsguard, Lewyn Martell and I,
would ride with the prince.
Before we left, the prince confided in me
that when he returned from this battle, there
would be a great many changes in court.
Despite my vows to the king, I confess I was
excited.
On the march to face Robert's army, we were
sure we would win.
We had superior numbers and we had Prince
Rhaegar.
His presence lifted the spirits of our men
and he looked every inch the king he was destined
to become.
But at the Trident the gods played a cruel
joke.
Robert proved the Baratheon words as his army
smashed through our lines.
Lewyn Martell was killed, I fell in combat
badly wounded and could do nothing but watch
as Robert's war hammer ended Rhaegar's glorious
reign before it began, and the kingdom that
would never be washed away down the Trident
with his life's blood.
Yet Robert spared me, insisting his personal
Maester tend to my wounds out of respect.